Sie futtern ständig Wildschweine.
*lustige Musik*
Sie verkloppen gerne Römer.
Die stürmen tatsächlich auf uns ein.
Und süffeln
selbstgebraute Power-Drinks.
Die unbeugsamen Menschen
aus Asterix' Dorf
prägten sehr
unser Bild der Gallier.
Waren sie immer aufs Prügeln aus?
Haben sie ihre Barden gefesselt
und nur Wildschweine verputzt?
Mit Geschichts-Profi
Mirko Drotschmann klären wir,
wie historisch korrekt
die Welt von Asterix & Obelix ist.
*lustige Musik*
Das Römische Imperium
gibt es schon lange nicht mehr,
dafür ein riesiges Imperium
rund um die Asterix-Comics.
Die gibt es seit den 60ern
und seitdem viele Adaptionen.
Es gab Zeichentrickfilme
und die Filme mit Gérard Depardieu.
Jetzt ist der neuste Film erschienen.
"Asterix & Obelix im Reich der Mitte"
mit Zlatan Ibrahimović.
Ich finde
die Zeichentrickfilme am besten.
Die habe ich
als Kind mehrfach gesehen.
Ich habe mich gefreut,
wenn die "bösen" Römer
auf die Fresse bekamen.
Heb' doch bitte deinen Kopf, Römer,
damit ich liebenswürdig sein kann.
Wir schauen uns
diese Filme genauer an,
anhand eines typischen Tages
von Asterix & Obelix.
*Musik*
Wir starten morgens
mit Asterix & Obelix im Dorf.
Der Schmied
macht gerade die Eisen heiß,
Häuptling Majestix
wird auf seinem Schild getragen.
Nur der Geruch der schlechten Ware
des Fischhändlers Verleihnix stört
und löst eine Schlägerei aus.
Eine Schlägerei.
Wartet auf mich!
Ansonsten ist es idyllisch.
Wie in einem ostfriesischen Dorf:
Steinbauten, Reetdächer.
Man kennt sich, man grüßt sich.
Mirko,
haben die Gallier wirklich so gelebt?
Es ist schwierig,
von den Galliern zu sprechen.
Gallier war ein Begriff der Römer
für eine Reihe von Volksgruppen.
Im Fall von Asterix eine keltische.
Der Begriff war abwertend.
Die meisten Quellen
aus Asterix' Zeit, also 50 v. Chr.,
sind römisch und griechisch,
weil die Gallier
alles mündlich überlieferten.
Römisch, lateinisch,
für mich ist alles griechisch.
Dadurch haben wir
ein verzerrtes Bild,
voller Stereotypen über Barbaren,
die man zivilisieren muss.
Manchmal auch bei Asterix.
Die Bewohner
sind blutrünstige Ungeheuer.
Schreckliche Barbaren.
Archäologische Funde
und neuste Forschung zeigen,
dass der Unterschied zu den Römern
nicht so groß war.
Wir wissen also,
der Begriff "Gallier"
ist irreführend.
Wir verwenden ihn trotzdem,
weil sie im Film so heißen.
Wir meinen aber
eine keltische Volksgruppe,
die auf dem Gebiet siedelte,
das im Film gezeigt wird,
nämlich die Bretagne.
Wir wissen auch,
dass die Forschung
anders auf die Gallier blickt.
Was sagt die heutige Forschung aus,
und wie passt das
mit den Filmen überein?
Man weiß, dass die Gallier
schon Staatsgebilde hatten,
mit größeren Siedlungen als im Film,
von über 1.000 Einwohnern.
Sie wurden Oppida genannt
und hatten städtische Strukturen.
Man zahlte mit Münzen.
Die Bewohner von Asterix
hätten dort gelebt.
Also Handwerker wie Automatix,
Händler wie Verleihnix.
Aber auch
die politische Elite wie Majestix.
Nicht so sicher sein können wir uns
z.B. bei der Rolle der Frau.
Frauen werden bei Asterix
als emanzipiert dargestellt.
Es gibt Anzeichen, dass einige
reich und einflussreich waren.
Das ist besser belegt
für einige Jahrhunderte vor Asterix.
Wie es danach aussieht,
wissen wir nicht richtig.
Was das gesellschaftliche
Zusammenleben betrifft,
finden wir vieles aus Asterix wieder
bei den historischen Galliern.
Es war nur größer,
komplexer und weiter entwickelt.
Die Filme sind aber keine
Dorf- und Gesellschaftsdoku.
Es geht richtig zur Sache.
Am Ende dreht sich alles um eines.
Eine kleine Prügelei
wäre was Feines.
Krieg mit den Römern.
Der wird auch schon mal abgehandelt
an einem schönen, sonnigen Mittag.
*Musik*
Gegen Mittag
spazieren Asterix & Obelix im Wald
und treffen meist auf 1-2 Römer.
Miraculix, ich glaube,
die Römer haben was verbrochen.
Im Dorf macht man sich bereit.
Jeder nimmt
einen Schluck Zaubertrank.
Als Waffe hat man das,
was man sowieso bei sich trägt.
Der Schmied seinen Hammer,
der Alte den Gehstock,
der Fischhändler den Fisch.
Dann kann es losgehen.
Die gallische Chaos-Bande
trifft auf eine akkurate Römer-Armee
und teilt ordentlich aus.
Hejaho!
Aber waren die Gallier
wirklich so krass chaotisch
mit der "Hau-drauf-Mentalität"?
Das Bild der kampflustigen Wilden
ist ein Stereotyp
der römischen und griechischen
Geschichtsschreibung.
Da sind die Verrückten.
Eigentlich stimmt
genau das Gegenteil.
Die so zivilisierten Römer
übernahmen ganz viel
von den angeblich
so wilden Galliern.
Die Gallier waren nicht für die
Hinkelstein-Industrie bekannt,
wie Obelix,
sondern für ihr
geniales Metall-Handwerk.
Sie hatten Kettenhemden,
Speere, Lanzen, Schwerter
und natürlich auch Schilde.
Also nichts mit Hammer,
Fisch und Gehstock.
Sie hatten gutes
militärisches Equipment.
und waren nicht chaotisch unterwegs.
Aber wenn die Römer Teile
der Kampfausrüstung übernommen haben,
müssten Asterix & Obelix nicht
ein bisschen aussehen wie Römer?
Ja, was die Kampfausrüstung angeht.
Ansonsten sind wir eher bei
der Darstellung wie in den Filmen.
Aus unserer Sicht
waren sie sehr modebewusst.
Sie trugen gerne farbenfrohe
und auch mal karierte Kleidung.
Sie waren auch bequem,
nämlich mit einem Vorläufer
unserer Hosen.
Es waren Beinkleider,
die in der Taille
mit einem Gürtel gehalten
und an den Knöcheln
zusammengebunden wurden.
Das zeigen die Filme.
Asterix' Helm fällt allerdings
in die Kategorie
künstlerische Freiheit.
Den Helm mit Hörnern gab es nicht,
noch weniger
eine Version mit Flügeln.
Etwas filmische Ausschmückung
darf sein.
Der Helm hat für Asterix
einen hohen Wiedererkennungswert.
Apropos Wiedererkennungswert,
wir haben noch nicht
darüber gesprochen,
warum die Gallier erfolgreich sind:
über ihren Zaubertrank.
Na also.
Wir glauben,
dass es den so nicht gab.
Aber Druiden wie Miraculix
gab es tatsächlich.
Was ist historisch über die bekannt?
Von den Druiden wissen wir
durch die Griechen und Römer.
Das ist aber
mit Vorsicht zu genießen.
Die Beschreibungen
sind aber nicht abwertend.
Römer und Griechen waren fasziniert
vom breiten Wissen der Druiden.
Z.B. vom Verständnis
der Kräuter und deren Wirkung.
Dazu zählen auch Misteln,
die Hauptzutat für den Zaubertrank.
Miraculix redet ständig davon.
Sie wurden wirklich verwendet
für solche medizinische Tinkturen.
Sogar in diesen Bronze-Kesseln.
Man kann von einem Trank
mit stärkender Wirkung sprechen.
Wenn auch nicht ganz so
wie bei Asterix.
Das kann man sich vorstellen.
Na gut.
Die Druiden
hatten auch noch andere Aufgaben.
Sie waren hoch angesehen
in der Gesellschaft.
Sie kümmerten sich
um die Erziehung der jungen Elite.
Sie waren Universalgelehrte
in Politik, Medizin, Philosophie,
Astrologie und Religion.
Sie waren auch unabhängige Richter,
z.B. um ein Verbrechen
zu bestrafen.
Oder wenn es Streitigkeiten
zwischen 2 Volksgruppen gab.
Ihr Urteil war unanfechtbar.
Wer dem nicht folgte,
der wurde einfach verbannt.
Das ist heftig, passt aber gut
zur Darstellung des Miraculix.
Er ist im Dorf der Weise.
An ihn wenden sich alle
bei Problemen und Streitigkeiten.
Druide Miraculix,
ich bin beunruhigt.
Er gibt Asterix und Obelix auch immer
einen guten Rat mit auf den Weg.
Sie haben zwar den Zaubertrank,
aber der Zwist mit den Römern ist nie
nach dem 1. Kampf schon vorbei.
*Musik*
Meist geben die Römer
nach dem 1. Angriff nicht auf.
Sie haben noch eine Hinterlist,
um das widerspenstige Dorf
der Gallier endlich einzunehmen.
Mal entführen sie Falbala.
Mal greifen sie
befreundete Gallier an.
Entschuldigung, ich bitte euch
um eure Unterstützung gegen Rom.
Biegen wir das zurecht.
Genau, Asterix und Obelix.
Und das machen sie auch.
Ein Krieger und ein Handwerker
gehen auf gemeinsame Heldenmission.
Mirko, wären beide auch
im echten Leben zusammen losgezogen?
Man muss sich die Gallier vorstellen
als ein Volk von Händlern,
Handwerkern und Landwirten.
"Asterix" spielt in der Zeit
eines tatsächlichen Krieges.
Das war der Gallische Krieg.
Darin eroberte Caesar
nach und nach gallische Gebiete.
Die Konfrontation mit den Römern
in den Geschichten von "Asterix"
gab es historisch wirklich.
Aber genau genommen gingen sie
schon 2 Jahre vorher zu Ende.
Das Gebiet, in dem Asterix wohnt,
wurde schon 56 v.Chr. erobert.
Aber diesmal scheinen die Römer
gewonnen zu haben.
Wenn wir das außer Acht lassen,
können wir davon ausgehen:
Asterix und Obelix
wären nicht gemeinsam losgezogen.
Sie hätten sich aber sicher
gemeinsam verteidigen müssen
gegen Caesars Eroberungszug.
Denn Caesar ging extrem brutal vor.
Er hat sicherlich über 1 Million
Einwohner Galliens getötet.
Noch mal, über 1 Million.
Und es gab
ebenso viele Kriegsgefangene.
Sogar Frauen und Kinder
wurden dabei versklavt.
Viele Völker haben aber auch
Bündnisse mit Rom geschlossen.
Denn sie hofften auf Unterstützung
bei Kämpfen zwischen den Galliern.
Das ist heftig.
Aber ein Bündnis haben ja
die Dorfbewohner genau nicht im Sinn.
Sie wollen ihre Lebensart
und ihr Dorf erhalten, wie es ist.
Gab es solche unbeugsamen Gallier?
Den gab es im echten Leben,
der hieß Vercingetorix.
Unter seiner Leitung
schlossen sich 52 v.Chr.
mehrere keltische Völker zusammen.
Sie waren vorher verfeindet.
Und brachten sogar kurzzeitig
Caesars Eroberungszug ins Wanken.
Blubb blubb.
Aber Rom
war am Ende doch zu mächtig.
Und hat sie endgültig besiegt
in der Schlacht von Alesia.
Gegen so eine Macht wie Rom
hatten die Gallier keine Chance.
Im Film ist das fürs Happyend
ganz anders dargestellt.
Gallier, ihr seid frei!
Asterix und Obelix
beenden ihre Mission
immer erfolgreich.
Trotz kleiner Zwischenfälle.
Und das
muss natürlich gefeiert werden.
*Musik*
Lagerfeuer,
Wildschwein und viel Alkohol.
So sieht der Abend
im gallischen Dorf aus.
Lasst uns das Fest beginnen!
Der Barde Troubadix
will Stimmung verbreiten.
Aber seine Lieder
kommen nicht so gut an.
Er landet gefesselt
und geknebelt am Baum.
Dort hängt er
den restlichen Abend ab.
Ein "gallisches Mobbing-Opfer".
Wir gehen den Abend mal durch
und starten mit dem Sättigendem.
Mit dem Wildschwein,
Obelix isst ja nichts anderes.
Im Film sehen wir auch ständig,
wie die gejagt und gegessen werden.
Mirko, war Wildschwein
ein gallisches Standard-Gericht?
Ein schöner Running Gag.
Aber die Gallier
aßen kein Wildschwein.
Die Tiere waren heilig
und deshalb für alle tabu,
auch für die Oberschicht.
*Obelix schluchzt.*
Aus ehemaligen Abfallgruben
kann man heute herauslesen,
welche Tiere geschlachtet
und gegessen wurden.
Das waren v.a. domestizierte Tiere,
also Rinder, Schafe,
Ziegen, Schweine.
Aber es gab nicht nur Fleisch,
sondern auch Getreide
und Hülsenfrüchte,
angebaut von gallischen Landwirten.
Schlechte Nachrichten für Obelix.
Aber seinen Kummer hätte er ja
in Alkohol ertränken können, oder?
Alkohol gab es auf jeden Fall!
Einige Gelehrte berichten sogar
von einer Neigung der Gallier
zu berauschenden Getränken.
Aber auch das
ist mit Vorsicht zu genießen.
So schildert
ein Bericht zur Eroberung Delphis
dass die Kelten zu betrunken waren,
um die Stadt einzunehmen.
Sie hätten den Wein pur getrunken.
Wein in der Antike
musste man mit Wasser verdünnen.
Das Trinken von purem Wein
galt als barbarisch.
Die spinnen, die Römer.
Wir sind also wieder
beim stereotypischen Bild.
Und können davon ausgehen:
Nicht alles hat so stattgefunden.
Aber es wurden
viele Amphoren gefunden,
die große Feiern mit Wein
vermuten lassen.
Keiner weiß, was wirklich drin war.
Na dann: Prost!
*Obelix hickst.*
Wein gab es also,
dafür aber eher Spanferkel
statt Wildschwein.
Bleibt noch der Barde.
Der wird im Dorf
immer gefesselt und geknebelt.
Weil er schlecht singt.
Mirco, ist den historischen Galliern
Mobbing zuzutrauen?
Pauschal kann ich das nicht sagen.
Aber zu 100% hätte sich keiner
am Barden vergriffen.
Der war nämlich
nicht einfach nur Dichter und Sänger.
Sondern v.a. das kulturelle
Gedächtnis jeder Volksgruppe.
Wichtig für eine Gesellschaft
mit einer nur mündlich
überlieferten Geschichte.
Er konnte das Heldentum
eines Kriegsherrn preisen,
ihn aber auch
mit einem scharfen Vers vernichten.
Und er hatte sogar die Macht,
durch seine heiligen Lieder
die Feinde zu besänftigen
und Kriege zu verhindern.
Mit ihm hätte sich also
sicher keine angelegt.
Das hätte die Götter erzürnt.
Und man wäre evtl. selbst
im nächsten Spottlied drangewesen.
Damit ist der Barde so etwas
wie der Influencer von damals.
Evtl. mit nicht so hoher Reichweite.
Aber dafür
mit gutem Kontakt zu den Göttern.
Verständlich, dass man sich
mit dem besser nicht anlegte.
Für den Geschichtsunterricht
taugen die Asterix-Filme also nicht.
Aber es gibt einige Parallelen
zu den historischen Galliern.
Vieles ist aber verklärt
durch die römische und
griechische Geschichtsschreibung.
Aber die Filme
wollen auch nicht überkorrekt sein.
Wir sehen in vielen Momenten
einen Seitenhieb
auf unsere moderne Gesellschaft.
Das macht den Witz aus und zeigt,
was bei uns alles schiefläuft.
Wir wollen weiter nichts
als den Passierschein A 38.
Hä?
Den Passierschein A 38!
Eine meiner Lieblingsszenen.
Wie ist es bei euch?
An welchen Film, welchen Moment
erinnert ihr euch bis heute?
Schreibt mir das mal.
Ein großer Dank
geht an Mirko fürs Erklären.
Schaut doch mal auf seinen Kanal.
Und postet
ein Wildschwein-Emoji von uns!
Grüßt ihn da.
Und vergesst hier bitte nicht
zu abonnieren, und die Glocke.
Das ist eine gute Idee.
Wir sehen uns bald wieder,
ich freue mich drauf.
Bis dahin, ciao.
Noch Fragen zu Asterix und Obelix?
Hier oben sehen wir,
wie brutal die 2 sind.
Hier unten
gibt es noch ein Video mit Mirko.